la douleur d'un conflit fratricide trois
ans de combat des millions de familles
séparées de réfugiés et de mort une
guerre déclenchée lorsque les forces du
régime de pyongyang
appuyé par la chine ont franchi le 38e
parallèle pour envahir le sud
objectif mais unifier la péninsule
cette histoire officielle est loin
d'être c'est la prise par les nord
coréens
quand une langue raconte dans son pays
natal
le régime affirme que ces séoul soutenu
par les états unis qui a lancé les
hostilités en plus de dépeindre la corée
du sud sous de sombres jours à l'école
on nous montrait les enfants familles en
train de mendier des femmes obligées de
se prostituer dit elle
zhang a elle-même était au coeur de la
propagande en tant que chanteuse dans
des troupes comme celles qui ont
participé à l'opération charme de la
corée du nord aux jeux olympiques de
2018 pour la jeune femme
les mensonges ont commencé à se fissurer
quand elle a regardé des films entrer en
contrebande montrant une corée du sud de
rêve aujourd'hui pigiste dans l'immédiat
elle raconte sur sa chaîne youtube
à quoi ressemble la vie ici l'abondance
j'ai une voiture jégo a indiqué free et
gti joue je fais porter des jupes
courtes sans que personne ne vienne
m'arrêter lancèrent alors qu'en corée du
nord on est tout le temps sur une jambe
reconnaît que tout n'a pas été rose au
début en 2008 quand elle est arrivée
dans la jeune vingtaine en corée du sud
la frustration partage de ce qu'en
pleurer d'être incomprise la langue du
nord comportent des différences les
petits boulots comme serveuse entre
autres pour celle d un l et peut mettre
à cedar à côté pour faire venir ses
parents c'est ce que veulent bien des
transfuges précise-t-elle de l'argent
pour payer des intermédiaires soudoyer
des gardiens pour sortir clandestinement
de la corée du nord en traversant
souvent à la nage cette rivière jusqu'en
chine comme les faits quand une jambe ou
encore en tentant de franchir la zone
démilitarisée la frontière entre les
deux corées chaque route apporte son lot
de risques et de périls plus de 30000
transfuge se sont installés au sud
depuis la guerre souligne-t-on dans ce
centre de recherche sur les droits de la
personne en corée du nord
elle ajoute que le flot s'est
considérablement réduit ces derniers
mois en raison des restrictions de
mouvement
en ces temps de kobe 19 mai
l'intégration des transfuges a toujours
été difficiles même avant à la pandémie
le procès s'est terminé sur un match
leur taux de chômage est plus élevé que
la moyenne sud coréenne elles sont
arrivés encore adolescent 2008
paquinou tsang tentait de cacher son
identité nord-coréenne
parce qu'on traitait alors différemment
cinéastes et réalisateurs pigistes comme
pour cette station qui diffuse des
émissions à destination de la corée du
nord
le jeune homme s'est su pleinement
aujourd'hui c'est bon on y croit s'être
fondu à la société sud coréenne pak
ui-chun dit qu'il est heureux même si
sans lui des amis des proches en corée
du nord
une certaine nostalgie
on la sent chez les parents de cannes
une jambe
l'élève dans l'une de ces vidéos sa mère
soutient que les poulets avaient
meilleur goût dans l'or parce qu'ils
étaient élevées au grand air son père
reconnaît qu'il est parfois dépassée
dans la ville se met la famille souligne
surtout les avantages dans le sud quand
on zhang a le coeur brisé
lorsqu'elle pense que ses compatriotes
du nord elle résume son pays d'origine à
un mot enfer elle évoque la fin les
longues heures de labeur pour un salaire
de misère là bas et elle ne voit aucun
espoir de réconciliation avec le sud
tant que la dynastie qui me restera au
pouvoir
soixante dix ans après le début de cette
guerre pas tout à fait terminée entre
deux frères ennemis ici annick bureaud
radio-canada civile